ah
hola bienvenidos a esta edición del
debate de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález nuestro tema de hoy nos aleja
de la coyuntura internacional de lo que
está sucediendo en ucrania y nos lleva
hasta méxico allí el presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador presidió la
inauguración oficial del nuevo
aeropuerto internacional felipe ángeles
que sustituye el proyecto del nuevo
aeropuerto internacional de la ciudad de
méxico ubicado en texcoco un proyecto
que ya había avanzado en su construcción
y que fue cancelado en octubre del 2018
tras una consulta popular que fue
promovida precisamente por el mandatario
a lo largo de su gobierno el presidente
lópez obrador ha reiterado su compromiso
de sacar adelante esta obra de
infraestructura entre otras así lo
mencionaba en una de sus intervenciones
a comienzos de este año escuchemos vamos
a inaugurar este año
el aeropuerto
ojalá
y los que
[Música]
y hablaron y escribieron
de que
íbamos a fracasar
y quien hoy vamos a tener a tiempo y que
quiere tomar una mala decisión al cerrar
al clausurar el proyecto del lago de
texcoco terminen reconociendo
de que fue lo mejor
que nos salvó el pueblo
que eso es lo importante de la
democracia
vamos a terminar este año también la
refinería de dos bocas ahí
este
es la ingeniería civil
la inauguración del aeropuerto
internacional ubicado en donde
previamente estaba funcionando la base
aérea de santa lucia contó con un evento
sencillo eso sí allí asistieron cerca de
1400 invitados pero no hubo discursos
tampoco hubo actos protocolarios mario
carbon el corresponsal de france 24 en
ciudad de méxico nos da más detalles de
lo sucedido a lo largo de esta jornada
89 pasajeros estrenaron la mañana de
este 21 de marzo el aeropuerto
internacional felipe ángeles en un
primer vuelo hacia villahermosa tabasco
al sureste del país asimismo el primer
vuelo que se recibió fue proveniente de
guadalajara jalisco y así inició viajes
esta terminal aérea que es una de las
mega obras prometidas por el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador construida
por el ejército mexicano y en tiempo
récord son 20 operaciones en esta
primera jornada y se espera que para
finales de año movilice a 2.4 millones
de pasajeros la capacidad en una primera
etapa de este aeropuerto es de movilizar
a 20 millones de personas y reducir así
la saturación que existe en el actual
aeropuerto internacional benito juárez y
conformar un sistema aeroportuario con
tres terminales la ciudad de mexico esta
de felipe ángeles y la de toluca
se estrenó esta terminal áerea con
invitados especiales
actos musicales de orquestas
estudiantiles
con pendientes pendientes en cuanto a
conectividad ya que no todas las obras
viales están concluidas así como la
ampliación del tren suburbano que
conectará a la capital del país con el
aeropuerto de santa lucia asimismo con
una degradación de la categoría aérea
que impide establecer nuevas rutas desde
y hacia eeuu sin embargo la venezolana
aerolínea conviasa ya opera en él felipe
ángeles esta terminal aérea que se
compone de 2 mil 500 hectáreas con 200
locales comerciales y un museo del
momento
este nuevo aeropuerto internacional
busca ser un aeropuerto de clase mundial
amigable con el medio ambiente eficiente
también funcional y que sea un emblema
de la presente administración y se
espera atienda a unos 100 millones de
pasajeros al año en su punto máximo de
operación es decir se espera pueda
satisfacer la demanda de servicios
aéreos de pasajeros para las próximas
cinco décadas este aeropuerto se une a
otras obras de gran tamaño que hacen
parte de este plan de cuarta
transformación con el que se busca
modernizar a méxico y generar también
empleo entre los planes del presidente
no solamente está este aeropuerto
internacional también está el
controvertido tren maya en la península
de yucatán la moderna refinería dos
bocas en el estado de tabasco y el
estratégico corredor interoceánico del
istmo de tehuantepec que unirá el
pacífico del sur mexicano con el caribe
todas estas obras han generado
controversia en méxico sobre todo a
nivel político en donde chocan todo tipo
de egos y también por los sacrificios
que representa este tipo de gastos
porque en otros lados hay que recortar
presupuestos para poder garantizar este
tipo de obras las megaobras del
presidente de méxico andrés manuel lópez
obrador son nuestro tema de análisis hoy
en el debate de france 24 y para
analizar este tema saludamos a claudia
villegas ella es profesora de periodismo
en la universidad nacional de méxico
también es directora de la revista
fortune ahí ya se encuentra precisamente
en la capital mexicana también más
adelante a lo largo del programa se va a
unir a esta conversación eduardo
esquivel él es analista económico y
columnista más adelante vamos a
establecer conexión con él ustedes
también nuestros televidentes pueden
participar en el debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas no pueden
hacer a través de las redes sociales no
se encuentran en facebook en instagram y
en twitter estamos como france24 el
guión bajo ese arroba santi logo que es
mi cuenta personal y nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas en torno
a este tema comienzo entonces con
claudia
bienvenida al programa gracias por estar
con nosotros claudia aquí en el debate
de france 24 y la pregunta de punto de
partida que quiero hacer es lo que
significa para méxico y para la capital
mexicana para la ciudad de mexico la
inauguración de esta terminal del
aeropuerto internacional felipe ángeles
en donde quedaba hasta hace algunos
meses la base aérea de santa lucía
muchas gracias santiago un saludo desde
la ciudad de mexico representa pues una
vieja añoranza de poder comenzar a
reducir como ustedes informaban la
concentración que se tiene en el
aeropuerto internacional benito juárez
es un aeropuerto que en momentos de gran
afluencia por ejemplo en picos
vacacionales o ante eventos como la
fórmula 1 simplemente se satura es un
aeropuerto que data pues ya de hace
muchas décadas
santiago y que se había buscado
construir en la zona de texcoco una
ampliación un aeropuerto que quedaba muy
cerca y que sin embargo además de los
problemas que tenía de problemas de
mantenimiento asociados a que se
encuentra en en la zona lacustre más
importante que tiene la zona
metropolitana de la ciudad de méxico
pues también está muy cerca de la mancha
urbana de la ciudad de mexico seguíamos
con ese problema de que un aeropuerto de
estas dimensiones en donde aterrizan
aeronaves muy grandes seguía muy cerca
de la mancha urbana lo cual a diferencia
de lo que sucede pues en grandes
capitales del mundo
parís/madrid
houston miami en donde el la distancia
promedio entre un aeropuerto santiago y
la ciudad la capital de las grandes
ciudades es de 25 27 kilómetros entonces
es importante que méxico comience a
mirar hacia el futuro porque necesitamos
un aeropuerto y ante el crecimiento de
la mancha urbana es se ha desconcentrado
santiago entonces creo que por seguridad
es lo primero que diría
es muy importante y después más adelante
me gustaría platicar un poco lo que
represento construir un aeropuerto de
más de 77 mil millones de pesos en medio
de la pandemia santiago tal vez es uno
de los puntos destacados de esta obra de
infraestructura muy destacada ahora para
el gobierno del presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador esto generó todo tipo de
discrepancias a nivel político qué
fuerzas se enfrentaron aquí para poder
llevar a cabo esta construcción de este
aeropuerto este proyecto impulsado por
el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador y que fue lo que chocaron allí
en ideologías políticas simplemente egos
entre los políticos o egos entre las
diferentes vertientes políticas de
izquierda a derecha allí en méxico
este es un aeropuerto de transición
entre dos regímenes políticos entre dos
modelos
económicos el anterior aeropuerto el
nuevo aeropuerto de la ciudad de mexico
que contaba ya con emisiones de deuda
que se iba a pagar con préstamos que al
ser cancelado se tuvo que entregar por
adelantado el pago de los rendimientos
por ejemplo a los tenedores de pensiones
es una disrupción total frente al modelo
que teníamos de participación privada
santiago de cómo los bancos veían en
este aeropuerto un gran negocio atado
también como les platico a emisiones de
deuda corporativa que estaba metida
metidas en los fondos para el retiro era
un proyecto pues asociado al pri porque
desde el gobierno de enrique peña nieto-
se buscó a través de pues mucho cabildeo
pero también tratar de convencer a las
comunidades después de una gran
confrontación que generó que méxico
pasará al ámbito internacional pues como
un país represor en el gobierno de
enrique peña nieto- cuándo pues se
violentaron muchos derechos humanos
porque en esa zona no querían el aire no
querían ceder sus terrenos entonces el
presidente de lópez obrador llega con
una consulta popular que tuvo sus
críticas estuvo pues cuestionada porque
en algún momento se dijo que pues se
había realizado entre los ámbitos como
bien comentadas de interés político pero
lo que es cierto es que en términos
ambientales en términos de ubicación de
marc mancha marcha de de mancha urbana
este aeropuerto santiago pues insisto
fue una transición política entre dos
modelos porque este aeropuerto lo
construye por completo el ejército las
fuerzas armadas fueron las encargadas de
costear los insumos de contratar al
personal de construcción de ejecutar
todo el tema de seguridad respecto a las
autoridades del espacio aéreo entonces
insisto yo creo que este megaproyecto de
todos los que ustedes han mencionado del
gobierno de lópez obrador es un emblema
de que se rompió un modelo económico
político y también de participación
privada que le iba a generar al país
grandes deudas santiago si
le damos la bienvenida a esta
conversación a eduardo esquivel analista
económico y columnista darle
establecimos la comunicación con él él
también se encuentra en la ciudad de
mexico hay en la capital mexicana
bienvenido eduardo bienvenido al
programa y quiero conocer su opinión
sobre lo que significa para su país y
para la capital mexicana la inauguración
de esta obra de este nuevo aeropuerto
internacional y ya iremos adentrándonos
en el debate de lo que significa esto a
nivel político que ya lo estábamos
empezando a analizar con claudia
bienvenido
este es un gran proyecto yo inclusive yo
me encuentro aquí en el aeropuerto
internacional felipe ángeles este es un
gran proyecto y
hay muchos mitos que no se cumplen que
es este
están todavía
resolverse eso de que la iniciativa
privada iba a poner todo el dinero para
el aeropuerto de texcoco es una mentira
seguiré el presupuesto del 2016 y 2017
ce se entregaron al proyecto del
presupuesto de egresos de la federación
más de 111 mil millones de pesos para
entrar a hacer los estudios lo hizo con
dinero de fonadin fueron 4 mil millones
de pesos que es un fondo perdido eso sí
nos iba a rescatar si se emitieron bonos
unos bonos que tienen como fuente de
pago este el tua que se cobra en el
aeropuerto de la ciudad de méxico y es
un capital semilla de
y luego este también nada
luego se hicieron otras voces banobras
hizo otros bonos que en este que tenéis
la fuente de pan de las afores eran
inversión de afores y entonces proceso
éste lo que ustedes llaman se priva el
yo tuve oportunidad de ver el estudio
que se hizo en
de texcoco hizo fonadin
y le resultaba que el suelo era fangoso
y que si iba a tener que invertir mucho
dinero
este cada año en el
repavimentado y que no se hundieran las
pistas entonces yo me era puramente de
capital privado era un exceso esto
llevará mucho retraso
ahorita si hubiéramos tenido ese
aeropuerto todavía no era oportunidad de
estrenar la clara además se está en la
terminal 2
bueno la terminal 1 y 2d del aeropuerto
de la ciudad de méxico y iba si va a
tirar tú se aeropuerto y si es guarda
que la terminal 2 todavía no se no se
amortiza claro
eduardo claudia qué sacrificios tiene
que hacer méxico en este momento para
llevar a cabo este tipo de obras no
solamente el aeropuerto internacional
que va a servir también a la capital
mexicana sino estas obras que
mencionábamos al principio del programa
el tren maya el corredor que unidad
mismo en el sur del país y también esta
refinería en el estado de tabasco que en
sacrificio se está haciendo el gobierno
mexicano para poder amortizar y poder
pagar todo este tipo de obras
que son inversiones millonarias y que el
presidente ha catalogado como obras de
seguridad nacional ya vamos a analizar
lo que significa ese esa categoría de
seguridad nacional comienzo con claudia
muchas gracias santiago en este momento
que se ha tenido que sacrificar que en
los presupuestos de egresos de la
federación durante los últimos 23 años
se ha privilegiado el presupuesto que se
destina a estos megaproyectos a cambio
que hemos tenido pues un crecimiento
diferenciado en regiones que
históricamente habían sido olvidadas por
el crecimiento
concentrado en el norte del país que
hemos tenido que sacrificar pues lo que
muchos analistas pedían y algunas voces
del sector privado que durante la
pandemia se entregarán mayores estímulos
a las
empresas y se pedía que esos estímulos
se dieran a través de las grandes
bueno tenemos que recuperar la conexión
con claudia en la ciudad de méxico
continúa entonces con eduardo haciéndole
la misma pregunta sobre los sacrificios
que tiene que hacer el estado mexicano
para poder llevar a cabo este tipo de
obras de gran calado allí en mexico que
sin duda alguna pues se traduce en tener
que cortar presupuestos en otros
programas o en otras áreas y que eso
pues va a tener repercusiones más
adelante eduardo
mira yo creo que los proyectos son
necesarios y lo que si este
he visto que no sólo tienen que ser los
grandes proyectos de infraestructura
como el tren maya como es
la refinería del dos bocas o en este
aeropuerto el tren-tram sísmico que yo
creo que va a ser una muy buena
inversión
este
pero si se están haciendo grandes
sacrificios
para presupuestales para llevar a cabo
estos proyectos pero en esta guerra de
ucrania nos ha demostrado que
necesitamos tener refinería así que no
podemos depender
desde el extranjero para la compra de
gasolina de
combustible
ya está en
el dueño de tesla dijo que había que
apurar la extracción de petróleo y de
gas porque las energías limpias estoy en
tiempo de la red guardé en esta guerra
pues nos ha venido a partirse claro
eduardo en términos de infraestructura
que la gran apuesta que está haciendo el
presidente de lópez obrador en qué
condiciones estaba méxico cuando llegó
el presidente lópez obrador que haya
querido enfocar buena parte de sus
esfuerzos en el gobierno para
desarrollar este tipo de obras méxico a
la vista de gran parte de américa latina
y por lo menos lo que se ve fuera de las
fronteras mexicanas es un país muy
moderno y es un país con una buena
infraestructura desde su punto de vista
como estaba la infraestructura mexicana
en términos competitivos
nota no era tan había dos méxico no
el sureste completamente abandonado en
el norte y el bajío con un desarrollo
para afuera
las cadenas con las cadenas es
de la industria automotriz con de la
industria electrónica pero esto no nos
estaba llevando a
al problema de las desigualdades se
hacía más desigualdad este
pues en la infraestructura dejaban
muchos proyectos se dejaron botados
fueron más entre en los gobiernos de
felipe calderón y
enrique peña nieto se dejaron botados
más de 300 hospitales
y se están rescatando a algunos otros ya
no no se dejó botada una refinería se
perdieron más de tres mil millones de
pesos en tula
y esto no sé pues no ayudaba pero en mi
modo de ver las cosas faltan
este es también los grandes proyectos
pero
necesitamos más proyectos más pequeños y
agua potable
[Música]
y de rellenos sanitarios y otros en
claudia cuál es su opinión en torno a
esta pregunta que le hacía eduardo de la
infraestructura mexicana que desde fuera
se puede ver como un país muy bien
conectado en términos de infraestructura
más moderno que muchos otros países de
la región mucho más avanzado y ahora el
gobierno se embarca en este tipo de
grandes obras de gran calado pero el
país en términos competitivos como
quedado como estaba también
muchas gracias la inversión en
infraestructura respecto al producto
interno bruto ha pasado de 2013 de 2.5 a
2019 a 1.5 el gobierno de enrique peña
nieto- en otras palabras en lugar de
invertir más en infraestructura
disminuyó el gasto la inversión que se
realiza en proyectos portuarios en
proyectos de desarrollo en carreteras
que sucedió un problema fue la
corrupción pero también que precisamente
en ese ánimo de pactar y de tratar de
utilizar el gasto de infraestructura
para temas políticos se detuvo lo que
estamos viendo en el gobierno del
presidente de lópez obrador es que en
medio de la pandemia
tuvimos un gasto contracíclico que no se
enfocó al rescate de empresas o al apoyo
para sostener sectores que
históricamente se habían visto
beneficiados
de santiago para responder tu pregunta
te diré en méxico tiene un rezago
histórico en desarrollo de
infraestructura para exportar para
crecer tenemos cuellos de botella en el
proyecto de trenes ahora mismo con este
aeropuerto de lo que estábamos
platicando es que el gran
cuestionamiento al gobierno de lópez
obrador es que es un aeropuerto que
quizás está aislado que hacemos una hora
50 minutos desde la ciudad de méxico
para llegar pero que que sucedió con los
proyectos de trenes de pasajeros que se
cancelaron durante el gobierno de
ernesto zedillo o los que no se hicieron
como el proyecto del tren de pasajeros
querétaro que se canceló por corrupción
en otras palabras creo que el proyecto
de infraestructura del presidente de
lópez obrador el tren maya y el
aeropuerto
apoyaron la inversión hacen falta muchos
más con sido con con eduardo pero
también hace falta que se genere
confianza ya para que el sector privado
esta aventura que está iniciando el
presidente de lópez obrador de liberar
sus macro proyectos santiago bueno la
corrupción que es el mal que está
enquistado en prácticamente todos los
países de américa latina para poder
desarrollarse es donde se estancan los
grandes proyectos de las naciones
latinoamericanas claudia continuó con
usted para hablar de un tema importante
es el tema del medio ambiente al
presidente mexicano lo han criticado
mucho por no haber
respetado unas recomendaciones
ambientales de hechas por la
organización de naciones unidas sobre el
proyecto del tren maya que es tal vez
uno de los proyectos más controvertidos
es en una zona que uno una zona del país
es fuertemente desarrollada por el tema
turístico en la península de yucatán en
el estado de quintana roo pero también
une algunas poblaciones que están muy
aisladas que están muy lejos de ese
desarrollo tecnológico que quieren
instaurar allí en mexico el tema
ambiental deja malparado al presidente
en este tipo de acciones que tanto se
cuida méxico en este tipo de
infraestructuras de la construcción de
estas infraestructuras en términos
ambientales
gracias es importante mencionar que el
proyecto del tren maya en sus equipos
directivos y de ejecución ha tenido
cambios el presidente de lópez obrador
no estar muy contento con lo que obtuvo
en la gestión de este proyecto no
tenemos mucha información en materia de
transparencia sobre lo que ha sucedido
con los macro proyectos me parece que
ese es una deuda que tiene por ahí el
gobierno del presidente de lópez obrador
y si hay muchas críticas respecto a los
grupos ambientalistas a los grupos que
protegen la flora y la fauna en la zona
también hay que decirlo hay grupos que
han aprovechado este proyecto para
tratar de generar confrontación política
la confrontación política no está
ausente yo creo que el presidente de
lópez obrador tendrá que exhibir en su
momento si se cumplieron con las
manifestaciones de
ambiental en una zona que es tan
importante para américa latina' santiago
eduardo usted mencionaba hace unos
minutos el tema de la refinería en el
estado de tabasco una refinería
importante por la coyuntura en la que
estamos en este momento por la guerra en
ucrania que ha llevado a que los
combustibles se encarezcan y la apertura
de esta refinería le permitiría méxico
prácticamente suplir su necesidad de
combustibles a nivel interno esto puede
traer amplios beneficios para la
competitividad mexicana pero que hay de
la apuesta por combustibles más limpios
aquí vemos que méxico le sigue apostando
a los hidrocarburos a los refinados de
petróleo y no le apuesta a
[Música]
y combustibles que sean más amigables
con el medio ambiente en esto méxico da
un paso para adelante para abastecerse
de combustible pero da varios pasos
hacia atrás en materia medioambiental
como lo ve usted
un milenio de hay una gran
es una gran ignorancia en este tipo de
cosas del gobierno de
andrés manuel lópez obrador le está
apostando a las energías limpias pero no
a la a las que la iniciativa privada ha
hecho que son la eólica y la
fotovoltaica la solar estas estas
energías este no funcionan todo el
tiempo y el steam
esas energías ya si hay un país que es
el que menos emite
[Música]
co2 a la atmósfera es méxico no
esté en canadá y eeuu
es mucho más lo que lo que generan de
energías sucias y es y el gobierno de
méxico le está apostando a las
hidroeléctricas del sureste del país es
que hay un proyecto de cambiar las
turbinas
en las hidroeléctricas de tabasco y de
chapas
12-14 refinerías un proyecto de más de
mil millones de dólares y con esto con
estos cambios de turbinas la generación
de energía limpia a través de las
hidroeléctricas
este el ecce este excedente
alcanzaría
alrededor de 6 plantas de eólica y 8
fotovoltaicas entonces este decide
eduardo
bueno retomaremos más adelante la
comunicación con eduardo sigo con
claudia lago la misma pregunta sobre la
deuda en materia medioambiental ya
mencionamos el caso del tren maya en la
península de yucatán pero qué hay de
esta refinería que le sigue apostando a
los combustibles fósiles a la extracción
de petróleo allí en la costa mexicana y
que le sigue apostando a este tipo de
combustibles cuando la idea a nivel
mundial es empezar procesos para pasar a
combustibles más amigables y recordemos
que ustedes tienen una de las ciudades
más contaminadas del mundo que es ciudad
de mexico precisamente por la quema del
combustible fósil de las fábricas y de
los vehículos que transitan allí
no sólo eso también tenemos un problema
de uso de
combustóleo que es un insumo que generan
las plantas de pemex y que compra la
comisión federal de electricidad y que
se ha usado para reducir los costos de
operación pero como decía eduardo el
gobierno del presidente de lópez obrador
está buscando que esta narrativa de el
sector privado principalmente
empresas españolas que cuestionan al
gobierno cuando trata de cambiar las
reglas de despacho las reglas para que
ellos participen y que de alguna manera
lo que hicieron fue ir avanzando sobre
el mercado de la comisión federal de
electricidad no tengan esos argumentos
santiago de que la comisión federal de
electricidad está contaminando o está
usando insumos como el combustóleo
sucios
de estar produciendo electricidad y
también me gustaría agregar que la
comisión federal de electricidad está
usando gas natural porque el gobierno de
enrique peña nieto- heredó uno de los
convenios más rentables para las
empresas gaseras que se conectan con
estados unidos pero si tiene razón el
gobierno del presidente de lópez obrador
está apostando por las gasolinas pero
por no importar las es que está
generando esta refinería y compro como
ustedes saben una refinería en deer park
texas
claudia adelante
puede terminar su idea adelante gracias
entonces lo que diría ahí santiago es
que si bien es cierto que la transición
energética está ya a la vuelta de la
esquina y que esto que sucedió en
ucrania y en rusia donde vimos que
depender de un combustible fósil como es
el gas natural nos deja muy vulnerables
a factores geopolíticos y bélicos el
gobierno del presidente de lópez obrador
santiago lo que quiere es sustituir la
gasolina que se compra porque méxico a
pesar de que solíamos ser un país
exportador de petróleo ahora importamos
el 70 por ciento de las gasolinas
entonces el reto y el desafío es cómo
sigues reduciendo la importación de
gasolinas e impulsos al mismo tiempo la
matriz para energías eléctricas y
limpias al día
claudia eduardo me queda un minuto para
finalizar el programa la conclusión de
lo que sigue para méxico en términos de
infraestructura de lo que puede venir
más adelante les pido que sea muy
puntual por favor y eduardo su
conclusión que sigue para méxico para
los próximos años para este país en
términos de infraestructura
no pos y tienen que acabar los proyectos
que ya se empezaron el tren
méxico-toluca que quedó quedó varado en
el sexenio de enrique peña nieto se
tiene que acabar se tiene que acabar en
la refinería que se dice que se estrena
en julio el tren si eduardo ti
no tengo que cortar porque me quedan
pocos segundos y necesito seguir la
dieta también haga la conclusión claudia
su perspectiva la conclusión
gracias que se cumpla la promesa del
secretario de hacienda- rogelio ramírez
de la o santiago de que se van a tener
esquemas públicos privados para la
participación en desarrollo de
infraestructura porque eso le podría dar
a méxico la oportunidad de recuperar el
8 por ciento que se cayó el pit durante
la pandemia santiago y gracias un saludo
eduardo claudia eduardo muchísimas
gracias por haber analizado este tema
para la audiencia de france 24 en
américa latina' ustedes pueden seguir
con la programación de france 24 siga
con nosotros
[Música]